they know that in the past in the recent
past including sometimes the present
they are racist and they have been but
better than they were and the fact that
they like you I think they're better
than they used to be but they're still a
lot of racist I think I think that that
party I I I think there's a lot of I
mean what do you call racism when you
say you want you know I mean I'll give
you a quote the remedy to pass
discrimination is present discrimination
the remedy to present discrimination is
future discrimination that's racism too
that's kendi it's kendi you know you're
all over it so yes I think where we are
in this country with respect to racism
I'll use an analogy based on you you
know lighting that and watching that you
know taper out is it's like the last
burning embers of racism that's where we
are actually I'm serious I'm just a
visual person all right I'll vote for
you you got me with that one